meanwhile a quarterback who is clearly a
step or two below the likes of aaron
rodgers or tom brady and who has to
every year contend with rumors that
there's going to be
some
a-list quarterback who takes his spot
derek carr meeting with reporters
yesterday during the ongoing off-season
program in las vegas with the raiders
still weird to see that here's derek
carr
uh
part of what he was asked about and what
he had to say in response and we will
analyze it on the other side
this seems to be the offseason unhappy
quarterbacks around the league and um
whether aaron deshawn russell a little
bit you obviously haven't had the
greatest situation around you to be fair
to say
but you haven't ever heard a peep from
you wha why why are you
that way i suppose you know no public
company something like that but
yeah you know josh that's a great
question honestly my goal josh was when
i got here to
you know give everything i have to this
organization um
let our fans know i'm giving it all that
i have and i will always continue to do
that on on season off season
and uh and whether the situation is
great or not that's okay people can say
whatever they want i know what i've put
on film i know the things that i've been
able to accomplish and i still want more
there's still more and i want to do it
here i don't want to do it anywhere else
i've said it over and over again i
i
i'd probably quit football if i had to
play for somebody else you know i i am a
raider
for my entire life i'm going to root for
one team for the rest of my life and
it's the raiders so
i just feel that's so strong in my heart
you know i don't need a perfect
situation i'd rather go down with the
ship you know i'm saying if i have to
you know that's just my personality
uh okay um who hacked my account
yesterday why complain when there's a
block button that was the that was
because he is very well known for
blocking people on twitter yes i also i
thought he was going to go into a full
hulk hogan flex there at one point when
he when he swept his arms outward yeah
what's with the hoodie that's that's
carved all the way up like coming like
whatever you know sun's out guns out you
know i mean let me let me just say this
though because i don't know if you heard
the question very well i think i got the
gist of it basically in an offseason
where we've heard complaints from guys
like russell wilson and aaron rodgers
and he may have mentioned desean watson
why haven't you said it why why why is
derek carr not complaining well how
about this he hasn't earned the right to
complain yet that's the easy answer
these other guys are all here he's here
or here he's not bad but he's not one of
the top five quarterbacks in the nfl
right and he hasn't proven that he can
get to the top of the mountain or even
approach the top of the mountain he's
never won a playoff game he's never
played in a playoff game he had a broken
leg the year that the the raiders made
it to the post season and it's not his
fault that he broke his leg but he
hasn't he hasn't even tasted the
postseason experience in a career that
dates back to 2014. so it would be
the height
of
presumptuousness for him to complain
about anything he's done nothing
to deserve the right to complain that's
the true answer in my assessment i
agreed i think you're spot on i guess
that's why we're friends i mean we don't
even talk about this stuff but i mean
that's the way i look at it yeah i mean
you're talking about complaining
i mean yes you're you're
if he complained to where he's at at
this point of his career the raiders
would be like okay
you know you're annoying we need to get
rid of you like we got to get rid of you
that's what they would do
he's not good enough to be annoying and
be a complainer like rogers watson and
russell wilson to your point
they could be so damn annoying and the
most annoying guy in the team and the
head coach is still gonna be like yeah
but
uh he's awesome and we're not good
without him and he's gonna make up 10
other reasons why he's not really that
annoying and that we really need him on
the football team because that's what an
awesome quarterback does you know derek
carr he's certainly getting there i mean
he's playing really good football but
you're right that's a different
stratosphere or a player we're talking
about right now those three quarterbacks
and yeah he he finally
has
you know planted himself in a
comfortable spot here after last year
where this was the first offseason we
didn't hear
oh well we evaluate every position and
we're going to look at every quarterback
on earth no he said it again said it
again
said it again yeah
you're i think you're right who said it
mayhawk did he say it ayaka always says
he does yes yes but i feel like there
was less gruden of that this year and
maybe not quite as much of a talking
point about that to where yeah he's got
nothing to say and he shouldn't say
anything and he needs a few more years
of what he did last year and then he can
complain if he wants but he's not there
yet
he's getting to an interesting point in
his career yeah remember he signed a
contract that he was one of the guys
that was at the front end
of that and and i keep thinking of the
old hands up the baseball bat where the
next guy gets more the next guy gets
more just because he's the next guy oh
the next guy's up he gets a little bit
more derek carr at one point for a very
limited slice of time was the highest
paid player in nfl history he's now
entering the final two years of that
contract 19.5 million this year
19.7 million next year he has not
complained about that and again
what's there to complain about what has
it i don't know does he deserve more
than that i don't know but
peter king and i did a draft a few weeks
back of the quarterbacks who are most
likely to be the next ones to make a
power play and peter selected derek carr
along the way and
i i uh
you know he's getting close to a point
where he can
kind of squeeze the raiders back they've
left dangling the past few years if he
has a big season this year and gets to
the playoffs and plays in a playoff game
and wins a playoff game and then he's
entering the final year of his contract
at 19.7 million that could get very
interesting
for the raiders because they may have to
renew their vows
with carr at a time when they've been
they've been looking for other options
and uh it may be that they just keep
staying with this guy but if they ha if
they do a new contract with him
if it's structured the right way
the the the
the option isn't going to be there for a
couple of years to move on to someone
else yeah no it's going to be a tough
decision it'd be a big year i think for
gruden and derek carr in that
relationship i think get to like to your
point where
uh i think this could dictate you know
the next three to four years of what we
see from the raiders at the quarterback
position if derek carr and you can win
games with derek carr and you can go to
the playoffs and he he's capable of
taking a team to the super bowl and
doing that and i know that's you know a
big statement for a guy that hasn't
played in a playoff game but
i've seen enough to think like he's not
the issue you put the right team around
him he can do it and then last year he
played really damn good football he
really did so he puts another year
together like you're talking about mike
where he plays the way he did last year
and the team is better
you know yeah he's got every right at 19
million dollars you know say what you
want derek carr's underpaid at this
point you know at this point there's no
doubt you talked about it he dances
around the top 10-ish of quarterbacks
after last year certainly the top half
of football in my opinion so you know
with that yeah there's justification
after this year to say you know i'd like
to have a little extension or something
here and you know he might have
the raiders by the proverbial you know
big ones there just in the fact of like
um okay what else are your options going
forward and gruden your offense and your
mad scientist and all that you've wired
me perfectly i'm i'm ready i'm an
extension of you so he will have a
little power in this situation if he
plays well again this year
let me ask you this because it occurred
to me while you were saying what you
just said yeah you got a very high
opinion of derek carr's skills you said
you can win a super bowl with them and
he really doesn't have
a great supporting cast right they've
been swinging and missing on some of
their first round picks the offensive
line was gutted this year you got
russell wilson complaining about his
offensive line and yeah no not a peep
from derek carr they got rid of like
four of the five starters and then
brought back one or two of them but if
if carr is as good as you say yeah and
it's the supporting cast not him that is
holding this team down
i kind of want him to make a power play
i kind of want to see that i want to see
that
you know that that quality that as i've
said before we don't like to see it in a
nine-year-old kid who has to win at
everything
but we admire it in a grown man who has
to win at everything right winning
everything gotta win at all costs
have we ever
gotten that vibe from derek carr
that he has that
that aspect of his personality that tom
brady aaron rodgers drew brees russell
wilson all the great quarterbacks have
like
he's kind of you know
we're complaining on behalf of these
other great quarterbacks because the
team's attitude is to those players you
just work here i feel like carr gladly
embraces hey i just work here i i i
think so too he does he gladly embraces
it you know i think it's a positive
thing he's the ultimate
team guy i do and i think he's shown
the last two years a little fortitude
and toughness to say that yeah you know
i think this this damn guy he is a
stubborn sob and gonna do whatever he's
got to do you know he's he's said and
done all the right things whether we
like it or not like listen he's a dork
right he's a dork with how he comes off
that way but if you got to be around him
a few times like i have that's the way
he is it's not a bad way i'm sure he's
liked in the locker room you know guys
probably go oh that's derek you know
that's his one cheesy comment of the day
you know he over exaggerates his point
to let you know like how innie is with
the raiders i'm so winning i'll never
play for a team ever again like i don't
really buy that but
he he's not going to even let himself
think anything else because i do think
he has some of that focus at least of
what you're talking about with some of
the other great quarterbacks where he's
just like i'm the quarterback of the
raiders i'm gonna be awesome uh gruden
said spider two why banana and then
check to 72
he's all in so that where i will give
him credit and then the play is starting
to match that i mean
he didn't leave plays or points or yards
on the field last year we certainly
could have watched those game and go
even the games they lost we never went
like man derek carr was the problem
right at least they're not in my opinion
you know he did what he had to do he's
not going to carry a team but if you
give him a little support like we saw
last year he can still make enough
happen and open your eyes and go damn
this guy's good efficient accurate and
make some plays from time to time
one thing we've discussed in the past it
relates to gruden that desire he has
to draw out
a certain aspect of the personality he
wants the quarterback to be
badass yeah he wants the quarterback to
to basically act like gruden does right
and and i feel like through three years
of that cajoling
carr has
gotten a lot closer closer to where
gruden wants me to be than where carr
was when the relationship began i
remember when the relationship began
someone that i know
who is familiar with the dynamics and
the personalities said this isn't going
to work car is going to crumble to his
credit he hasn't crumbled to his credit
he's responded and he's he's followed
gruden where gruden is leading him
to become the badass that gruden wants
yeah no
i i think that was all that was we all
questioned that i think right we were
all a little bit like man can that
really work together derek carr
you know christian values all those type
of things and there's gruden snarky
swearing saying things all of that
yeah i questioned it that was my biggest
question was whether those personalities
could co-exist
but yeah he's gone all in and he's
changed himself you know in a big big
way to where like i always think about
you know my my dad's ex-coach bill
parcells he used to say to my dad and
i'm gonna butcher this to a degree here
you know i don't want i want a
battleship commander not a cruise ship
coordinator or something like that you
know when my gist is there and i think
we're seeing that with derek carr i mean
there's a number of times last year
where he looked over to the sidelines
and he was swearing at john gurdon and
he was saying things like nope you're
wrong i know what i'm doing and shut the
hell up and doing all that and gruden
might not like it at the time but
ultimately he is going to like the fact
that derek carr is taking ownership you
know he's got an answer for everything
that's the big thing to me that's when
gruden knows you know what you're doing
and that's where i finally got in a good
place it's like hey you know my offense
now you're walking off the field the
pipe didn't go good are you going to
give me the right answers to why i
didn't go good right away and be all
over it and to me when i see derek carr
i always see him talking talking talking
and gruden kind of like shaking his head
like yep you were right okay and they
walk away so there's something there and
he's made a lot of progress
and and let me take this to the logical
conclusion if and when
derek carr becomes the full-blown badass
that john gruden wants him to be
and essentially the frankenstein monster
takes over the lab
that's when
he starts to be as upset as a russell
wilson and aaron rodgers right you go
into mike mayok and you say what what
the hell is up with all these guys that
you're you're giving me to play with i
want some better players i want some
input i want to be involved in this he
hasn't gotten to that point yet maybe
that's where he gets after this year i
want a new contract and i want to have a
seat at the table as we try to fix this
team because i'm not going anywhere i'm
a raider for life
so if i'm ever going to do anything in
this league you got to get me some
better raiders around you yeah yeah i i
think you're right he has another year
like he did last year
and you know it's still like man only
darren waller was the bright spot you
know i know they got josh jacobs and
he's awesome talk about the pass game
options but you know we've talked many
times henry ruggs was a little
disappointing last year there's no doubt
about it that wasn't great you know
there is no nelson aguilar and i don't
think anybody was looking at him as like
a superstar to begin with right so you
got that you know hunter renfro good
football player but like derek carr
played amazing football it's 27
touchdowns it's nine interceptions it's
over a hundred and a quarterback rating
it's over four thousand yards and at no
point do i think anybody who evaluates
football should go the raiders have top
five or top ten skill position guys you
know so to that point yeah if they don't
start playing better and he plays the
way he's playing then he's got real
merit to be like hey i'm i'm pretty damn
good i've done everything you've wanted
i lead these guys
and you know you haven't supported me
the best to where he he has every right
to ask for more money and be a pain in
the ass after the offseason and i'll sit
here and stick up for him and it sounds
like you will too
by almost every metric last year was his
best season although i'm looking at his
stats here i had forgotten he's a
three-time pro bowler it's been a while
well probably 15 2016 2017 i know but
there's certain guys out there who we
think are good quarterbacks who have
never been to a pro bowl so it's been a
while 2017 was the last year but uh
look one other thing before we take a
break right he made the comment i'll
probably retire
i i would probably quit football if i
had to play anywhere else that is a
noticeable adjustment from the comment
he made a year or two ago that i'm the
quarterback of this team as long as i
want to be that that was an unrealistic
expression of how life is in the nfl no
you're the quarterback as long as they
want you the moment they no longer want
you you're gone this one is more
realistic although when he throws in
probably
it doesn't quite have the same thing to
it i would well you know what i i would
quit well i would probably quit probably
quit yeah if they
if you you you're gonna if you're gonna
make that outlandish statement you gotta
drop the probably and say i'm a raider
for life and i would quit football if
they ever got rid of me but you don't
wanna have to you don't wanna have to
cash that check
uh one of these days because and that's
it okay that's the other side of it too
right
i i wonder i know we got to take a break
but i wonder yeah
what if he was just suddenly available
next march yeah free agent mm-hmm would
there what what kind of interest
do you think i mean it would be in a
derek
i think i think there'd be more than
uh more than plenty i think there'd be
more you know it's not going to be top
level interest you know it's not going
to be aaron rodgers desean watson
russell wilson you know we got to trade
the farm for him but that team that be
looking for a going man we need a
starting quarterback and we need a good
one and we don't have to give up maybe
three fur
future first round picks or four future
like some you know it's something a
little more realistic he would be the
next guy i think at the top of that
market after those marquee names that we
mentioned
so like
you know when you see an andy dalton and
arrive fitzpatrick getting 10 million
dollar contracts on a one-year deal
that's the that's the floor for the
veteran starter
um he deserves way more than that 20 to
25
yeah i mean yes i think you could
justify 25 to 30 right now with some of
the guys that are in that price range
i'd go well yeah i'm sorry think about
what you want but that's the current
price for
you know good quarterback play he's a
good quarterback he is he hasn't had the
best circumstances you mentioned the
three pro bowlers i kind of tried to
take a shot at it but back at that time
damn at least two of those three were
legit appearances i mean that 20 was
that the 2017 year of the 2016 year
where he was in the mvp conversation
until he broke his leg it was pretty
damn good football 2016. yeah there was
some clutch moments late in games i mean
he did some things back then where you
went whoa like maybe we got a superstar
kind of coming along here and then it
kind of plateaued for a little while but
we're seeing it pick up and uh i think
he's too easily disrespected a little
bit because yeah he's a little over
exaggerator like you're talking about
and then the raiders haven't done the
best job of like making sure everybody
knows he's the man so then he gets well
because john gruden's the man that's the
thing john is the face of the franchise
maybe the quarterback should be but it's
been gruden gruden gruden the last three
years and carp you know what what's
car's option when you're dealing with a
force of nature personality like john
gruden what are you really going to do
that's right and maybe that's why at the
end of the day gruden hasn't
i don't want to psychoanalyze him in the
same segment we psychoanalyzed aaron
rodgers maybe gruden doesn't want to
surrender face of the franchise
to a badass top-end quarterback he wants
to want a top-end quarterback but he
doesn't want that guy to supplant him as
the face of the raiders franchise i am i
you know i don't think that's crazy i've
definitely had the thought in my life
before where i went i don't know if john
gruden really wants brett favre or
peyton manning because then if things
don't go well we're gonna look at his
offense have i have i thought that
before you know me i wear my heart on my
sleeve of course i have so yes that
thought has crossed my mind uh in my
heart of hearts i don't know if i really
believe that but it has crossed my mind
certainly
it's easy to blame the quarterback when
you believe that there's a better
quarterback out there that would run the
offense better but right if you get that
better quarterback and it still sputters
and ate the quarterback right right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports